alrededor de 200 migrantes en su gran
mayoría venezolanos además de
colombianos Ecuatorianos y haitianos se
encuentran en medio del desierto entre
chile y Perú esperando una oportunidad
para poder cruzar y retornar a sus
países pero con la llegada del ejército
peruano a la zona limítrofe sus
posibilidades disminuyen porque la gran
mayoría de ellos carecen de documentos
al respecto el funcionario
stefanduyarick portavoz en la
Organización de las Naciones Unidas ha
llamado a Perú y chile a que dialoguen
para que traten de encontrar una
solución a esta crisis migratoria en
realidad los migrantes se encuentran en
el desierto entre chile y Perú en una
zona donde no tienen cobijo no tienen
agua no cuentan con alimentos ni
servicios sanitarios es por eso que la
Organización de las Naciones Unidas les
ha pedido a Perú y chile
priorizar opciones que procuren el
bienestar de los seres humanos Mientras
tanto amnistía internacional así como la
organización de refugiados ha calificado
como un error en la militarización de la
fronteras amnistía internacional ha
acusado a los gobiernos de Dina boluarte
y de Gabriel boric de ejercer políticas
que son crueles e inhumanas según el
organismo porque señala que violan
convenios internacionales Y en lugar de
establecer una solución agravan
torpemente la situación convirtiéndola
en una crisis humanitaria
y chile ya ha hablado de un posible
corredor humanitario hay avances en este
tema o en otras posibles soluciones
justamente los funcionarios peruanos y
chilenos están evaluando La gran
posibilidad de Establecer un corredor
humanitario se mencionan que trabajan
propuestas en las cuales se priorice el
libre tránsito de mujeres embarazadas
niños y ancianos al respecto el ministro
del interior peruano Vicente Romero
anunció que a nivel de las cancillerías
se trabaja bajo un concepto integral
buscar una solución pero que sea una
solución regional a un problema que no
solamente sea de Perú y chile Mientras
tanto por el lado Sureño el
subsecretario en interior de chile
Manuel monsalve dijo que la intención de
su gobierno es Buscar un paso
humanitario que permita que muchos
ciudadanos extranjeros que se encuentran
en Chile puedan tener un libre paso para
retornar a sus países de origen y que
esta situación
se normalice y ya no haya más problemas
de gente sufriendo en zonas desérticas
con Total vulnerabilidad no solamente a
lo que es la falta de alimentos
seguridad sino también a las mafias de
tratas de personas